>> Laura: TODAY'S RADICALIZED
DEMOCRAT PARTY HAS MOVED FURTHER
AWAY FROM THE VOTERS THEY NEED
TO WIN IN 2020.
THEY STILL HAVE NO CLUE HOW TO
SPEAK TO THE WORKING CLASS WHITE
VOTERS, LET ALONE HOW TO GET
THEIR VOTES.
WE TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT ABOUT HOW
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LEAVING THE
WHITE WORKING CLASS BEHIND.
IT EXPLAINS WHY THE PRESIDENTIAL
WON IN 2016.
BUT NOW WITH THE LEFT TRYING TO
WOO THE WHITE WORKING CLASS
AGAIN, HOW IS TRUMP GOING TO
PROTECT HIS SIGNIFICANT VOTING
BLOCK.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE CAMPAIGN
MANAGER FOR TRUMP 2020.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE AT 2020.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE.
NOW, WHAT IS THE CAMPAIGN GOING
TO DO TO LOCK DOWN THAT BASE
VOTER?
SOME TRUMP VOTERS TURNED AGAINST
REPUBLICANS IN 2018.
THAT'S A FACT.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO BRING THEM
BACK?
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT SAID FROM '14 TO '18 THAT
SUBURBAN WHITE WOMEN LEFT.
THEY DIDN'T.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PEOPLE COME
OUT FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CYCLES.
NOW, LOOK, I THINK THE PRESIDENT
HAS DONE THINGS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BUDGET, WITH
FAMILY LEAVE, I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE
WAY THE PRESIDENT IS PUSHING
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE.
>> LAURA: WHAT DO YOU MEAN
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE?
>> PUSHING AGAINST THAT, MEANING
THAT DO THESE MOMS REALLY WANT
THEIR KIDS SITTING IN LINES
WAITING TO SAY, HEY --
>> Laura: BUT THEY FREAK OUT.
THE WOMEN FREAK OUT BECAUSE OF
THE TWEETS, THE TONE.
I ALWAYS SAY, LOOK, THAT'S PART
OF WHO HE IS.
HE CONNECTS WITH THE VOTERS THAT
WAY.
THAT'S HOW HE DOES IT.
BUT FOR WOMEN, IT'S LIKE THEY
LOVE THE CHARMING TRUMP, WITH
THE ARM AROUND SOMEONE, A LITTLE
SELF-DEPRECATING, WHICH WE SEE.
BUT WOMEN LIKE THAT KIND OF
CHARM.
OBAMA HAD IT, CLINTON HAS IT,
AND TRUMP DOES HAVE IT.
HOW DOES HE DEPLOY IT MORE
EFFECTIVELY?
>> MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO SHOW MORE.
ONE THING I SAY WHEN I INTERVIEW
IS HOW GREAT HE IS IN PERSON AND
HOW FUNNY.
HE'S ACTUALLY A FUN GUY.
AND HE REALLY LIKES PEOPLE.
>> Laura: BUT HE SEES IT AS A
SIGN OF WEAKNESS TO COME OUT ON
STAGE AND BE TOO JOKEY.
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS.
I'M THE PRESIDENT AND I'M GOING
TO KICK BLANK AND TAKE NAMES,
WHICH PEOPLE ACTUALLY LIKE.
BUT THIS ELECTION THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE CAUGHT OFF GUARD.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
BE ON THE OTHER SIDE YET.
I THINK THIS PRESIDENT IS ONE OF
THE BEST MARKETERS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
I THINK HE UNDERSTANDS THE
PEOPLE AND HOW TO COMMUNICATE TO
THE PEOPLE.
HE'S GOING TO MOVE IN A WAY
BASED OFF OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO STAY
STRONG.
HE'S FIGHTING FOR THIS COUNTRY.
HE DID THIS FOR NO OTHER BUT TO
SAVE THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
ON FOX WAS TALKING ABOUT, MAYBE
HE REALLY DOESN'T WANT TO RUN IN
2020.
OTHERS HAVE SAID THAT.
IS THERE ANYTHING TO THAT?
>> WE'RE BUILDING ONE OF THE
LARGEST POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS IN
HISTORY.
I GO IN WEEKLY AND GIVE THESE
REPORTS.
HE WOULD BE WASTING A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME,
WHICH HE DOES NOT LIKE TO DO.
>> Laura: SO, WE CAN PUT THAT TO
REST?
>> YEAH.
AND I HOPE SO, FOR MY OWN JOB'S
SAKE.
>> LAURA: YEAH, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO BE DOING?
POLITICO REPORTED THAT SOME
ADVISORS ARE TELLING THE
PRESIDENT TO HOLD OFF ON 20
RALLIES.
IS THAT ACCURATE?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S
ACCURATE.
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT DOING IS
MIXING OFFICIAL EVENTS WITH
CAMPAIGN RALLIES.
HE NEEDS TO GET ON THE ROAD ALSO
AND TALK ABOUT ALL OF HIS
ACHIEVEMENTS AND GET OUT THERE
AND DO THOSE THINGS.
BUT RALLIES AREN'T GOING AWAY.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
OUT THERE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO GET
OUT THERE AND ENGAGE WITH
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: SO YOU'RE GETTING
EMAILS AT THESE RALLIES.
>> CELL PHONE NUMBERS.
>> Laura: NOW, PEOPLE SAY BRAD
IS SO YOUNG.
HE'S LIKE THE TECH GUY.
THEY SAID IN 2016, WHO IS THIS
GUY?
AND THEN HE ENDS UP WINNING.
AND NOW WE UNDERSTAND OTHER
CAMPAIGNS ARE TRYING TO FIND
THEIR OWN BRAD.
THEY'RE BRADDING IT.
>> I BECAME A VERB.
>> Laura: SCALING UP.
>> THEY ALL TALKED ABOUT HOW THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO RUN
A CAMPAIGN.
NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO COPY HIS
CAMPAIGN.
I WISH THEY WOULD COPY HIS
POLICIES BECAUSE HE KNOWS THE
RIGHT POLICIES TO FIX THE
COUNTRY AS WELL.
IT'S I -- IRONIC THEY'VE CHOSEN
THIS.
MOST OF US HAVE OUR OWN
INDIVIDUAL TRACK.
IT'S NOT BY AN ADDRESS.
WE CREATE OUR OWN MAPS AND STEPS
ACROSS THE INTERNET AND WE TRACK
THAT.
>> Laura: ONE CANDIDATE YOU'RE
FOCUSED ON?
>> I JUST SAID, TODAY I SAID I
HAD TO GO TO THE OFFICE TO FIND
A BIGGER BINDER TO TRACK ALL
THESE CANDIDATES.
IT'S GOING TO GET SO THICK.
I'M FLIPPING THROUGH THE PAGES.
I DON'T SEE A CLEAR PERSON
STEPPING UP TO THE PRESIDENT.
NEW MEXICO, MINNESOTA, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, NEVADA ARE THINK ARE
GOOD PLACES FOR US TO BE RIGHT
NOW.
IT'LL BE A GOOD NIGHT IF I GET